good morning they paced the cold streets
of Aberdeen providing Aid to those who
have nothing
a group of people who bring help to the
homeless in a time of escalating crisis
I started over a year ago now and when I
started we were seeing kind of up to 20
people a day giving them blankets
sleeping bags food and clothes whenever
they needed it now because of the cost
of living crisis and also the
homelessness crisis we're seeing it can
be up to about 65 people a day
talk me through what life is like on the
streets at the moment
Gary hasn't had somewhere to call home
for more than 30 years this winter he
says is worse than ever this is the name
it's just you just want to give up a
pill left behind my situations but
there's no facilities out there no other
people
the most recent official statistics
paint a grim picture they reveal around
250 homeless people died here in
Scotland last year much higher than
pre-pandemic times and a deteriorating
Trend which is causing grave concern for
what lies ahead it's a massive concern
the biggest issue for me within that is
the age profile of people the vast
majority are under 45 and the trauma of
experience in homelessness that does
lead to premature aging it leads to
worsening of health conditions this is a
survival map and it takes 44 crisp
Pockets here in Inverness Jillian makes
sleeping bags for the homeless using old
crisp packets a cost-effective idea with
far-reaching benefits
the group that I'm part of and they got
feedback from a guy who sleeps on the
streets
um and there was like tears in his eyes
he was so delighted with this because
it's just life-changing a small gesture
in just one rural community in a country
where those without a home Fear The Long
Winter ahead Connor Gillis Sky News